the fall of constantinople in 1453 is
considered by many to be one of the most
important events in human history
to some modern historians it marks the
end of the medieval period
and to others it merely marks the final
end of the long drawn-out decline of the
roman empire and the beginnings of
ottoman control over this region
but how did the contemporary people of
europe react to this event
so after the city's fault amendment you
can now call me the conqueror ii
the first europeans to hear about the
news outside of the city itself were
venetian and genoese traders
and they immediately returned to their
respective homes and spread the news
to which the response in those cities
was absolute terror
not because of constantinople's
importance historically or religiously
but because their trade had just been
impacted and they really liked money
news spread further and it wasn't long
before the city of rome and the papacy
knew of constantinople's demise
the sitting pope nicholas v was
absolutely terrified and he immediately
put out the call for a crusade to retake
the city
now he had this reaction for two main
reasons the first was that
constantinople's capture now meant that
the ottomans could turn their full
attention to the north the second was
that rome was now the last of the five
major christian cities not under the
control of non-christians and as a
result those that lived there assumed
that they would be next
there was also some salt in the wound
since roman constantinople were making
great strides in fixing their previous
schism
so what about the rest of europe and its
secular rulers well in france the king
was obviously disheartened by the news
but much like his english counterpart he
was busy fighting a war and so was a tad
preoccupied
also leaving the kingdom that you ruled
for several years meant that it was open
to being usurped or perhaps re-invaded
by those you just defeated
as for the holy roman empire their
relationship with the byzantine empire
was a tad more complicated whilst the
leadership there saw the city of
constantinople as a bastion of
christianity it was populated by the
wrong sort of christians
whom everyone had spent the last 400
years condemning his heretics and so
frankly there was no love lost
also no one could argue about who was
the true successor to the roman empire
anymore
all of this said the holy roman empire
now knew that the ottomans would be
pushing north
the emperor at this time frederick iii
was much more concerned with internal
problems and keeping his domains in line
and so he had little to spare for any
crusade
as for the other major catholic nations
of europe their responses are basically
non-existent meaning that in all
likelihood it wasn't that much of a big
deal to them or they simply had more
pressing issues
but what about europe's leading
non-catholic nation the orthodox
principality of moscow well its prince
vasily
ii had previously had a falling out with
the leadership of constantinople due to
its aforementioned making up with the
pope he had previously declared the
moscow orthodox church to be independent
of the byzantine one and with
constantinople now gone
his was now the leading branch and so he
was just fine with it and as vasili's
successors would go on to do
moscow could now claim to be the third
rome and the latest in the succession of
the roman empire of antiquity
and so from this we can see that for the
most part europe's reaction barring that
of the italian states was fairly muted
this was mostly because the fool of a
city of heretics even a prestigious one
like constantinople had little immediate
effect on them
and as for the pope's crusade well
nicholas did soon try to force the hands
of europe's secular leadership but
before he could begin assembling a
christian response he caught a small
case of death
meaning that no attempt to retake the
city was ever made
i hope you enjoyed this episode and
thank you for watching with a special
thanks to my patrons
james bissonette kelly moneymaker the
pastry section marvin casou
rob waterhouse danny maloney mo aaron
the white james castaneda
jordan longley marcus azner gerry
lambdon gustav swann rasheed ali
colin carson copper tone izzy david
silverman spinning three plates
winston k wood spencer lightfoot maggie
paxkowski
matthew shipley anthony beckett
fortunate calf robert wetzel lexy
schwinn and skye chappelle